[Music]
welcome to Tijuana we are on this
beautiful rooftop Ayala cusan the local
popped up a beautiful sandwich and then
would you believe I'll get some help and
make a Caesar salad but is good news the
Caesar salad was literally given birth
to in this incredible city and it was
Caesar Cardini so I put a twist on that
first off but doctor so that it was
sound overall there but first off I'm
gonna start with some useful red onions
okay
lightly slice them okay so just roughly
chopped and if you're gonna go kind of
messy camera will use one of the right
ingredients and that means everything
low so red onion for me way more
exciting than the white onion some
sweeter this harsh and a little bit of
oil
into the pan now Jenna so that's onion
scary
here
sweat it down first okay so just salt
no I don't get them more flavor
okay start our booth take a touch off
steady tone a peaceful short tell you
something sliced in half
but I did chunks the one that's coming
out in the onions you see that can I
literally change the dynamics of the
onion give a little bit of spice in the
pasta a little like goodness coming out
and just crumble that
flavors in there incredible all the
poblano peppers the rest of amazing
Chili's give that very nice fry up Kara
onions break down that's two these off
okay
this is almost like your sort of perfect
spicy sandwich sandwich let that render
what house Wendling
but it will touch
regarding that
you do all that oil coming out okay how
cool is that he's really beautiful
then that breakdown okay
take some cilantro literally just chop
it up
so lots of English and then
just use a local cheese yes sir that
will happen okay and it's a beautiful
almost like their version are very sort
of a tight mozzarella no shake from all
you do now is just literally open that
up
and put the kiss they walk up there not
be useful
mixture
from
that starts to melt and bring that all
together nicely
beautiful again just fill that back
stop marrying that's got it about
literally brings our whole thing
together
for that useful very beautiful now
let up strimmer away it's like that huh
okay from that we'll start laying this
out on the bottom
Mercato on
use the back of the fork okay
just getting over lime
from that I see
so
turn that off ease down to that
what
so these are these
from there just take a couple of lettuce
leaves
no no solution what is that margarita oh
my god listen when you're in Mexico
so strong eyes are extra strong just for
you do mine doctor I'm a peaceful
sandwich effigy we make and exciting to
see the Sabbath a place for cycling of
course I came so where do we start
I'm gonna put a touch of garlic annoy
after the Catholic we're gonna put it to
be or Worcestershire sauce which is how
many she's just she's got a sauce in it
that's two shots okay so which sauce
goes in there I'm gonna put a pinch of
chilli I think is important to give an
extra kick right so then passed out yet
sugar as we say in Italian and chili
paste yes you can put as little or as
much as you want
it doesn't really matter the good thing
about the anchovy paste
then you don't need to add any salt no
it's already salty nicely seasoned
nicely seasoned then we go creme fraiche
was in there just to give a little bit
of lightness so and Dijon mustard our
judicial masses because you can use
English mustard if he wants so far is
with the visual mass is slightly sweeter
it's not too pungent sure okay but whisk
it out or mix it however you want to do
is finish this to do touch-ups right
oh yes okay she's gonna go fantastic
with the Chancellor Walker Casa de
Oaxaca now egg yolk everyone but I'm
gonna try my very best I'm gonna put one
in there okay so one goes to another
these okay I'm gonna put a touch of
honey just a little honey another nice
so you give it the extra sweetness
who does that making a Caesar salad here
in the same city they get Bert come on
come on
that's your Tabasco yeah goes in that
you know the good thing about this
dressing yes we should have followed the
traditional way to do it yeah I think
you can do pretty much whatever you want
take he laughs you are in Mexico you
need to do a little tequila
now the secret word is the secret is to
toss the salad leaves gentle gentle
okay so we're gonna put a summer set of
leaves in here yeah the hearts of the
leaves not not the outside because
otherwise that you uh now you pick up
with your fingers don't push it down
don't push it down you just want to lift
it up and gently close it
what about this one here AHIMA I need to
become a goes in there which has been
marinate and some of the cheese can you
crumble some of the cheese please chef
say sorry for the wrong
you know why this salad is so popular
right because this is the ultimate way
that the Italian people
minimum effort maximum satisfaction
beautiful and we go to spork scratching
if you can put them on top just crumple
them woman please what the war no our
know our doors o our Lord o our the
water comes from an decima that's
fantasy duster with a beautiful Caesar
salads pala Ram ji and and a nice
margarita is flowing over the top that's
a must
plum cheese
[Music]